we are unique in our capacity for self
reinvention and in times of existential
threat we have completely reinvented
ourselves before and often it's
interesting if you look at the history
of our ancestors in Africa pre humans in
Africa it's often in response to climate
change that we've invented and refined
new capacities for survival this map
here on the left this is a place called
pinnacle point near the southern tip of
Africa and it's the place where a lot of
anthropologists now think that the
origin of modern humans may have taken
place there's an archeological site
there where it seems as though these
were the survivors when the human race
are hardly pre humans almost went
extinct about a hundred ninety thousand
years ago there was a genetic bottleneck
and we were almost completely wiped out
down to probably fewer than a thousand
individuals and this may be where we
made our stand pinnacle point and we had
to look learn a completely different way
of surviving because up to that point we
were hunter-gatherers but there was an
ice age in in Africa at that time and we
couldn't hunt the way we were used to
because the game died out because
because it was there's a climate change
there was nothing to hunt and the people
with pinnacle point found ways to hunt
for shellfish and they invented new
technologies and this is the origin of
what is called long-chain complex recipe
technology
and what that means is these are
technologies where you have to go
through some complex set of steps to
produce something like a smelting of
metals or heat treatment of rocks so
that the the product that you're getting
is not obvious from the ingredients you
start with the steps are are its
long-chain complex recipe technology and
it requires new levels of language and
cooperation and you have to be able to
teach it to the next generation and
there also there's art here and evidence
of pigments and personal adornment so
this may be where we became human it may
not be but the point is there are many
examples like this we're faced with
catastrophe we reinvented ourselves and
reinvented ourselves in ways that
required cooperation and invention on
larger scales and that's what we humans
are good at and when people tell me
there's no way we're gonna harness
ourselves and create this society where
we actually are able to use our
technology as a mostly as a survival
tool rather than a to threaten ourselves
I asked them
imagine trying to describe a modern city
to the people of pinnacle point and the
way we live now will be very hard to do
and maybe that's just as hard as it is
for us to imagine the reinvention that
we are perhaps beginning now
[Music]